[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chef's want to play in the garden and
I'm really excited today do you know why
we're going to be cooking one of the
most primal and the important dishes
mankind has ever eaten a fresh garden
salad now the one I'm talking about is
unique you may not know this but some of
the oldest people on earth alive today
are found in the Middle East
specifically in the Mediterranean on
islands that are quite steep they have
to walk a lot they eat a lot of olive
oil they eat a lot of fresh vegetables a
lot of fish and they live past 100 years
old this is one of the reasons today I'm
going to make you a Greek salad I
learned how to make when I was a child
living on the island of Cyprus we would
often eat this for lunch the ingredients
have to be all 100% fresh now I don't
fool around it comes to fresh herbs and
spices I grow my own that's why we're
right here you see these pots I make
sure that every day if I need mint if I
need parsley if I need oregano I've got
it I come out with the basket and I cut
my own I tell you this is the way to go
I want a little fresh mint will Allah
[Music]
save all you know when you just take a
leaf like that and you smell that it's
so deliciously fresh and sweet and minty
all right here we go
let me introduce you to the ingredients
today first of all the basic core to
this salad it doesn't have any lettuce
in it this is made from the core
fundamentals of the Mendut Mediterranean
type we're going to have some pepper
cucumbers you can decide which ones you
like all kinds of different tomatoes and
I've chosen some heirloom tomatoes the
classic red onion but here's the secret
that so many people don't know anything
about there is a spice in the Middle
East called zatar they Zaca exactly it's
spelled za8 t AR now this is a very
fundamental basic it's been around for
thousands of years and it's the spice
that gives all kinds of flavor to all
kinds of different dishes so with the
air loo
the whole concept here of these Greek
salads is chunkiness you don't want
razor thin tomato you want chunky
everything's chunky bunky about this
salad because you're putting it into a
salad inside a PITA later on so you want
that chunky monkey action so the best
way to start with the tomatoes take off
the top get a little base on the bottom
and now cut into chunks all right don't
be afraid to experiment time will help
you look at the chunkiness here now
we're gonna go to the cube this is the
core to any any Mediterranean salad you
want to start with cucumber now you take
the two bottoms off using your blade but
remembering the chunk is the bunk and
what I like to do with this piece is
often just test the queue Kyle keep it
back and like it's almost a bagel
[Music]
spectacular whoop now at this point
you're going to do something very
interesting you're going to introduce to
these first elements a little bit of the
tsaatan even though the zatar will be
coming into the actual dressing what I
like to do is tease the vegetables with
a little sprinkle of the zatar so that
the flavor starts to be introduced right
into the flesh of the tomato and the
vegetable all of it of course the onion
red onions are a huge debate in salad
community when they talk about this
because some people don't like the taste
of onion in this particular dish I love
it it adds a crunchiness to it now on
the chunky-monkey side on this I don't
want big chunks of onion the too
overpowering
I want to go thinner almost string like
that's what I like so I cut the onion so
that I can do the medallions and form
little ringlets that's what works now
this is where the real secret starts a
lot of people think oh well I'll just
buy some dressing I'm starting I'm going
to be using a juicer for the first two
letters and then I'm going to hand
squeeze the last one as one of my
secrets to get a little palpable
personality a little texture in
the actual dressing so we start with the
classic just take a lemon cut it in half
put it in the juicer see like this and
of course the juicer takes out the pulp
now here's another little secret a lot
of people think well you just put lemon
and olive oils together here's a really
interesting way to go if you want to
introduce a different element something
that people say what is that I'm not
sure what you've done there that's when
you introduce a little drop of lime
juice oh now I'm using a really crazy
expensive olive oil called only reserva
it's from flora this is a brought to
America by a man named Frank Giustra who
absolutely loves his his trees in Italy
and he has this handmade the price he
charges for this is a joke it's
ridiculously expensive but is it worth
it I have to admit yes it's spectacular
but I'm using it because when it comes
to olive oils let me tell you a little
secret you should always put a little
bit on your finger like this just a
little taste of the virgin oil Oh
magnificent what we're looking for here
is a grassiness a unique flavor that
these trees had when they were
pollinated and grew into olives and so
you get this beautiful you know I must
tell you something olive oils like wine
you really have to understand the
differences of the varietals this is a
particularly beautiful grassy gorgeous
virgin olive oil I keep it in my wine
cellar as a matter of fact what am I
going to do now I'm going to introduce
it to that lamb oh here we go now what's
the right consists what what percentage
should all be olive oil you it's going
to float on top of the lemon there is no
specific amount that you put it you have
to have a feel I generally like to see
about around 1/3 because now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to whisk into
it a little bit of the SATA now this is
very important you want a very tiny
wisk something small surgical and
precision you want to take just a little
amount out like this you know but is
that a teaspoon there's a lemon seat I'm
gonna get rid of how'd that get in there
okay here we go I'm putting it on top
you see the little sesame seeds they're
toasted Oh excellent
now I'm whisking it together to get this
into a suspension all right there's
still a lot of lemon in there so that's
gonna be very tart but I don't mind that
necessarily but wait we're not finished
we're almost finished remember we went
into the jar there and we got some mint
remember this fresh mint and hand rip
them right down leave a little parsley
now this is just a preference a lot of
people say oh when you're doing it
parsley in the salad I said what I'm
doing is I'm adding different textures
now we are there this looks spectacular
what I'm gonna do first is I'm gonna
show you a pita pocket this is a
mountain bread from the Middle East
everybody's seen pitas and we're going
to just quickly take it cutting it in
half all right so what we're gonna do
now is we're going to take the salad
pour some of this fantastic dressing
rush oh oh yeah oh yeah then we're going
to just honey can you get me the little
flipper deals so what I want to do here
is just I'm not beating it up I don't
want to bruise it I just want to make
sure that all the elements of this salad
are covered with that fantastic dressing
I made now I haven't introduced the
olives for a specific reason
first what I'm going to do now is I'm
going to fill up a pocket mix it up with
the big chunks you're just introducing
tomato with those peppers with the
onions it all goes into the pita pocket
then you take out of the brine a few of
the olives and you top it
top if you wanted feta cheese you could
do that too but I'm not doing that I've
decided to go total vegan on the first
bite all right here we go I'm gonna make
a mess here so I put this bowl under it
oh the onion the olives the cucumbers
the pepper the period up the za time I
have to have another bite this reminds
me of my youth like you have no idea
walking up amongst the sheep and goats
to the top of the mountain in the
Cypress pines in the beautiful sunshine
and having this for lunch
it is soap well I just wanted to get you
through the whole experience this out
you can't go wrong with it everybody in
your family is gonna love this the
secret was a zatar and a little bit of
the lime juice and the lemon and great
olive oil okay so what do you think it's
tactile it's just hard to eat sometimes
a Falls apartment that's part of what
makes it special it's very very tasty
but my family of yours we'll see you
soon okay what goes absolutely great
with a resounding like this well it's a
fantastically
it's a blush wine it is absolutely
gorgeous of children Ellison spectacular
[Music]
[Music]